إنه مشهد يجب أن يكون مليئًا
بالبراءة، لكن هذه الرسومات التخطيطية
للمنازل ترسم صورة لجميع هؤلاء
الأطفال الذين
فقدوا منازلهم للنازحين الذين أصبحوا الآن
ملاجئ مؤقتة في وسط
غزة ويعيشون في طي النسيان وليس لديهم مكان
يذهبون إليه في الجنوب حيث يتم دفن المزيد من الأطفال في مكان
آخر
أسقط الجيش الإسرائيلي منشورات تحذيرية
يوم الخميس تطالب المدنيين
في جنوب غزة بالتحرك والبحث عن
مأوى، وهي إشارة تنذر بالخطر على أن
التوغل البري الإسرائيلي قد يوسع قريبا نطاقه
العقابي
حذر خبراء حقوق الإنسان في الأمم المتحدة يوم الخميس من أن الانتهاكات الجسيمة التي ترتكبها
إسرائيل تشير في كلماتهم إلى
إبادة جماعية في
طور التكوين بينما يخيم الظلام على الأطباء
في الجنوب الذين يتصارعون بالفعل مع
تأثير حملة القصف الإسرائيلية المكثفة،
هناك مخاوف متزايدة بشأن
ما يمكن أن يأتي بعد المشاهد اليائسة
من شمال غزة التي دمرت بالكامل تقريبًا
بسبب الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية المتواصلة
تظهر مدى خطورة الإبادة الجماعية.
يمكن
أن يصبح الوضع سريعًا
تقول القوات الإسرائيلية إنها لا تزال نشطة
في وحول مستشفى العفير، وهو أكبر مستشفى في غزة،
وتزعم أنها عثرت على
نفق تشغيلي في
مجمع المستشفى مع عدم إمكانية الوصول إلى المجمع.
في إليفا، سيستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت
لإثارة المخاوف بشأن سلامة وأمن
أكثر من ألف
مريض وطاقم طبي محاصرين الآن
بالداخل، ونحن نبحث في خيارات
الإخلاء الطبي ولكن هناك
الكثير من المخاوف الأمنية، وهناك الكثير
من القيود اللوجستية.  خياراتنا
محدودة إلى حد ما، حيث بدأت تظهر ادعاءات حول استجواب أشخاص في إيليفر
وحتى تجريدهم من ملابسهم،
بينما يقوم الأطباء
بتفصيل القرارات المروعة التي
يضطرون إلى اتخاذها، بما في ذلك
بتر الأطراف لوقف انتشار
العدوى ولكن مع
انقطاع الاتصالات مما يقطع شمال غزة عن
الكثير  من العالم الخارجي، ليس لدى CNN
القدرة على التحقق من هذه الروايات
وقد تواصلت مع الجيش الإسرائيلي للتعليق.
تمت مشاركة
الأطفال المبتسرين في العناية المركزة مع العالم،
ولا توجد طريقة لمعرفة ما إذا كانوا لا يزالون على
قيد الحياة، وبعض
آخر الأصوات التي سمعت
قبل إسكات أصوات الموجودين داخل مستشفى
الشفاء، بشير سي إن إن في
القدس